I've been a television comedy writer
for almost 25 years.
I have written sketches and animated shows
and sitcoms,
but for the last decade,
my real passion has been
the study of ethics.
It's a classic cautionary tale, right?
You move to Hollywood,
you get seduced by the bright lights
and the fast cars,
and before you know it,
you're reading 18-century
German philosophy.
(Laughter)
I've always been an intense rule follower.
When I was in kindergarten,
our teacher would tell
everyone to line up,
and I would immediately line up
and then I would look
at all the other kids
who were still goofing off,
and I would think, "What are they doing?
Did they not hear her,
she said to line up."
I rinsed my mouth with mouthwash
for at least 30 seconds every night,
because on the label, it says
"Use for 30 seconds."
I know, I'm irritated by me, too.
(Laughter)
But the real reason
that I became interested in ethics
is because in 2005,
I royally and epically
screwed something up.
So, 2005, my wife JJ,
driving along in slow-moving traffic
bumps into the guy in front of her.
Police officer looks everything over,
doesn't see any damage,
they exchange numbers
and they go on their way.
A couple days later,
we get a notice that the guy
wants 836 dollars
because, according to him,
the entire fender needs to be replaced.
This is happening
during Hurricane Katrina.
JJ and I had just been
to New Orleans on a trip,
we had really fallen in love
with this beautiful city,
which was now literally under water.
I was very riled up.
This was hitting me really hard.
So I went and I looked at the guy's car,
and if I got very close,
and I strained my eyes,
I could just barely see
this little line on the crease.
It looked like the mark you make
with a pencil on the wall
when you're trying to hang a picture.
And I told the guy, essentially,
that he shouldn't care about this.
I told him that things like this
were why car insurance rates in LA
were so expensive.
I told him that cars get
little dings and dents all the time,
and he was stupid to care about that.
I told him that there were
more important things in life than this,
like Hurricane Katrina.
And then I made him an offer.
I said that I would donate 836 dollars
to the Red Cross Katrina relief fund
in his name,
if he agreed not to file
this claim and fix his car.
He said he would think it over.
So I went back to work,
and as very confident people want to do,
I started telling all my friends
about how awesome I was being.
(Laughter)
And then they jumped in
and started pledging more and more money
if this guy would agree
not to fix his car.
So suddenly, it was 2,000 dollars,
then it was 5,000 dollars.
In like, a day and a half,
I had pledges from hundreds of people,
all across the country,
of more than 25,000 dollars
if this guy would agree not to file
an insurance claim and fix his car.
And by the way, he has no idea
this is happening.
He is completely in the dark.
I started a blog,
where I gave people
hourly updates -- yeah.
(Laughter)
It's beginning to dawn on you
what a bad idea this is, right?
I started a blog, gave people updates,
I got media inquires
from news programs, from NPR.
I had a dream of rescuing
New Orleans by myself,
(Laughter)
with nothing more than my computer
and a fire hose of self-righteous anger.
And then I started to feel
sick to my stomach.
And so did JJ, at the exact same moment.
We both were suddenly overcome
with this awful feeling
that there was something
very bad and wrong
about what we were doing,
but we could not pinpoint what it was.
I just remember thinking,
"Alright, I don't care about cars
getting little dings and dents,
but this guy does.
Is that wrong somehow?
I don't think that's wrong.
And also, is this little,
tiny negotiation that we're in
really worth all of this fury
and rage and shame
that I'm whipping up
and sending in his direction?
I don't think it is."
So I did what any rational person
would do in this situation.
I started crying, and I hid under my bed.
(Laughter)
And then, I started reading philosophy.
And I started calling
philosophy professors
and asking them to talk this out with me.
And in the process --
yeah, and they all, by the way, did it,
because philosophy professors
love talking about philosophy.
The drop of a hat,
they will all talk
about philosophy with you.
So in the process,
I learn all of these incredibly
wonderful theories
that the smartest people
who have ever lived
have developed over the last 2,500 years
that help us make better decisions
and become better people.
For example, I learned about Immanuel Kant
and the categorical imperative.
So Kant says, when we're
about to do something
we have to design a rule or a maxim
that we could will to be universal.
Meaning, we have to imagine,
what if everyone did
what we're about to do,
what would happen to the world?
Would it be OK or would it get
all screwed up?
So the maxim I'm designing here
is something like,
anytime two people
are in any kind of negotiation,
one of them can drag into the negotiation
an entirely unrelated global calamity
(Laughter)
and tell the other person
that they shouldn't care
about whatever they care about,
because they should care
about that instead.
That world would suck, right?
Like, your sister borrows
five dollars from you,
you ask for it back,
she says, "How dare you care
about five dollars
when the polar ice caps are melting?"
No one wants to live in this world, right?
Kant also says, by the way,
that you should treat people
as ends in themselves,
and not a means to an end,
meaning, you shouldn't use people
to get what you want.
Well, that's what I was doing.
I also learned about Aristotle
and the study of virtue ethics.
So Aristotle says there's certain
qualities we should all have.
Things like generosity and courage
and friendliness and mildness,
and he wants us to practice them every day
so that we not only have them,
we have them in the exact right amount.
We don't have a deficiency of them,
and we don't have an excess of them.
Now virtue ethics can be kind of,
maddeningly imprecise,
but at the very least, it was pretty clear
that I was exhibiting an excess of anger
and maybe a deficiency of friendliness.
I wasn't nailing it, is the point.
Like, I definitely
was not getting it exactly right.
Then I learned about utilitarianism,
made famous by Jeremy Bentham
and John Stuart Mill.
And this one actually
gave me a shred of hope
that I was doing something good,
because utilitarians only care
about the results of our actions,
they only care that we are creating
more happiness and pleasure
than we are pain and suffering.
So yes, I'm being obnoxious
and moralistic,
and I hand it to this guy,
causing him some amount of pain,
but an enormous amount of money
is going to be given
to people in great need.
So the amount of happiness I’m creating
outweighs the amount
of pain and suffering.
But the utilitarians also said
that when we're calculating
the amount of happiness
or pain we've created,
we can't just think about the one
person we're dealing with,
we have to think about the fact
that everybody in our society
will now both know this happened
and will fear that it could
someday happen to them.
And since we've already seen
what a terrible, stinky world
I was trying to create,
everyone in our society would become
a little bit bummed out and sad
by what I did,
and so the total amount
of pain and suffering I've created
might actually outweigh the happiness.
I never got a straightforward
answer, obviously,
because Aristotle never wrote
about, like, fender benders
involving horse-drawn carriages
in ancient Athens.
But at the very least,
it sure felt like Jeremy Bentham
and John Stuart Mill
would be a little disappointed in me.
And it sure felt like Aristotle
would be a little annoyed,
and it sure felt like Immanuel Kant
would wave a disapproving finger at me.
And if all of the world's
greatest philosophers
are on one side of a debate,
and you are on the other side ...
(Laughter)
You fucked up, OK.
(Applause)
So I called the guy.
I apologized profusely,
I told him the entire story.
He was very kind and forgiving,
which was an enormous relief to me.
I told him I had already cut him a check,
which was in the mail.
I went back to the blog,
I told everybody the outcome.
Most people, not all, but most of them,
thought it was a pretty happy outcome.
I encouraged them to give money
to the Red Cross anyway,
because giving money to hurricane victims
is a nice thing to do,
and in the end,
more than 25,000 dollars
was indeed donated
to the Red Cross
Hurricane Katrina relief efforts.
Don't applaud that,
because that's the happy
result of a bad event.
So why did this embarrassing,
miserable mistake that I made
make me want to continue
to study moral philosophy?
If I told you that you
were going to be on Jeopardy,
how would you prepare?
You would read some trivia books
and flip through a world atlas.
If I told you that you were going
to take a half-court shot
at an NBA game
for the chance to win 50,000 dollars,
how would you prepare?
You would get a basketball,
you would go to the YMCA
and you would practice hucking up
half-court shots.
Well, you're probably
never going to be on Jeopardy.
You are probably never
going to take a half-court shot
at an NBA game
for a chance to win 50,000 dollars.
But you will, I guarantee it,
at some point,
become embroiled in a complicated,
confusing, ugly,
gut-wrenching moral dilemma.
That is just a fact of life on Earth.
There will be a dilemma
in which there is no clear rule to follow.
There is only a kind of,
vague investigation
and everything you do
seems like it might be wrong.
So how do you prepare for that?
By reading theories of ethics
and understanding what they say,
what they mean,
how they purport to help us
make better decisions
and become better people.
And by the way,
just reading these theories
is no guarantee
that you will actually
make the right choice
when you're inside
one of these complicated
and tangled ethical dilemmas.
You can take all the practice
half-court shots you want
at the YMCA,
but when you set foot
on the floor of the NBA arena,
and there are 15,000 screaming fans,
you're probably still
going to throw up an air ball, right?
But if you've prepared,
you will increase your odds of success.
You will increase the chances
that you sink the shot
or that you at least get the ball
close enough to the rim
that you don't embarrass yourself
and become a meme.
(Laughter)
Understanding ethical theories
is how we increase our chances of success
at simply being human beings
who have to negotiate
with other human beings.
And to me, there is nothing
more important than that.
Thank you.
(Applause)